[Music]
it just shows him uh
i have a name for myself and he knows
who i am so he better not think about
nobody
melee's greatest rivalry was never about
mutual respect
i would be lying if i you know didn't
really want to [ __ ] beat his ass it
wasn't even about skill
[ __ ] up left i want to [ __ ] up left and
i want to [ __ ] up left him i want to
[ __ ] up left him i want to [ __ ] up left
him i want to [ __ ] up left him
left him it was about two players who
couldn't
stand each other i have been pretty
upfront about the fact
that i hate him as a person maybe in two
years understand
that sometimes talking [ __ ] and then
getting destroyed
for the 15th time in a row might be the
reason you'd play badly
this is the story of two of melee's most
controversial players
and their bitter rivalry
jumps out of his chair i'll take that
department
yep
[Applause]
how many times have we seen hbox nail it
with that four there
[Applause]
[Music]
super smash bros melee is a game known
for its rivalries
over it's roughly two decade long
history it's created countless
legendary match-ups but one feud in
particular has defined the game for the
last couple of years
leffen versus hungrybox oh leffen vs
hbox has actually been
they have had a long rivalry and it's
gotten a bit personal
at times these guys do not like each
other
it's a rivalry between the two best
players in the world
a rivalry between two controversial
players who have both been called
villains at some point in their career a
rivalry between a god
and a god slayer hungrybox's legacy in
melee predates his rivalry with leffen
though see
this guy is one of melee's five gods
mango armada mew2king ppmd
and of course hungrybox for over half a
decade
these five players won every single
tournament they attended
and the community called them gods for a
long time
hungrybox was considered the weakest of
the five often he'd get
so close to victory only to have it
snatched away from him by mango or
armada
but eventually hbox overcame those
losses and
put himself in contention for the title
of the best player in the
world
he recovers german is a tournament
[Applause]
winner
[Applause]
these days hungrybox is pretty popular
but that wasn't always true
and there are still some members of the
community who can't stand him
who threw this at me
[ __ ] off dude [ __ ] you
there are three main reasons why people
hate hbox his onstage antics
some behind the scenes drama and of
course his main
jigglypuff and then obviously mango
means puff
and conveniently at that tournament hbo
has his like
breakout performance and i was like oh
i guess i hate jigglypuff too well then
you can relate to me yes
she has been like been a torture for me
for like
past [ __ ] she has been 17 years tonight
for a decade
almost two for me unlike the rest of
melee's top tier characters jigglypuff
is slow so to make up for the speed
difference great jigglypuff players try
to slow the piece of the match down to a
crawl with defensive play
and camping and once jigglypuff players
have their opponents where they want
them
well that's when they use rest a move
that is almost
always a one-hit ko the pressure's on
playing around each other right now
armada not giving him anything
he gets that that could be
[Applause]
what a sequence from hungrybox
obviously using jelly puff at the
highest level is super difficult and
hungrybox is a great player for doing it
but some fans don't see it that way for
them watching jigglypuff play a match is
slow
boring and unfun in the sudden death
armada just ran out of it and kicked him
that does not count right fox won he did
not actually win
yeah by our by the community rules
percent is uh what determines
i don't know if you can hear this in my
headset but like listen to the crowd yo
the crowd is not happy
everybody says what are you gonna do
but hungrybox is the master of that
unfun character
and he has spent years dominating the
scene with puff
but among all of hungrybox's haters one
stood above the rest
a young upstart from sweden who toppled
melee's hierarchy and made a name for
himself by meeting
all five gods leffen he's toast dude
i feel that way there's i see slop
coming from eugene king yeah we can't
there's not the time for sloppy you know
what it really is he's just running it
left him right that's it
that's it and levitt takes it over
mewtwo king of three stalker dreamland
leffen has made history
like hungrybox lethen also had a bit of
a reputation for being a villain
in the smash community the things he
says like really pisses me off this is
just so stupid
why why would he do this he's popping
off i'm smarter than you i'm better than
you
he just has this mentality of i'm a king
and you're just some peasant
he shouldn't get away with it during his
rise leffen was
cocky he was an amazing player and he
knew it
and that kind of rubbed some players the
wrong way especially people in the
european smash community
in 2013 leffen was banned from european
smash tournaments
after players accused him being toxic in
a document known as evidence.set
so evidence. was basically a way to sum
up
a lot of wrong things that me and many
others
saw from leffen we felt like
we have to do something because this has
been going overboard
for a long time leffen's band was
eventually lifted because well
he seemed reformed he wasn't toxic
anymore at least not to other players
but he was still arrogant and he wasn't
afraid of speaking his mind
i don't need to say anything everyone
knows what i'm going to
say and it's going to be 5-0 that
that's how it's going to be wait i won
four out of the five summer majors
uh-huh
and i was like and i lost two best of
three sets
and you won how many oh right right from
2013 onwards muffin climbed the melee
rankings
but there was one of his peers that he
just couldn't
stand hungrybox
while weapon may have respected
hungrybox as a competitor he
hated him as a person sometimes esports
beefs are just for show
people like to talk big online but they
always seem to chicken out when they
meet each other offline
that is not what happened with leffen
and hungrybox
whenever they faced off at tournaments
both of them made sure to let everyone
know
just how much they hated each other uh
the saying that like there's two kinds
of people in this world
hbox fans and people who met him how old
is he like 22
21 i don't know maybe in two years
understand
that sometimes talking [ __ ] and then
getting destroyed
for the 15th time in a row might be the
reason you'd play badly
the rivalry truly began in 2014 when
hbox did a little bit of showboating
after beating left in a salty sweet
and that is it
hungrybox said yo real talk did you
forget who i
am i'm one of the top four players in
the playlist
um i really wanted the four stock really
badly i know he didn't want it but
it just shows him i have a name for
myself and he knows who i am
so he better not think i'm a nobody
because they just got wrecked and the
rivalry has only escalated since then
everyone knows that when leffen and hbox
face each other in bracket
it's a must-see event because the salt
will
flow so here we go this is uh
tough for leopard to make this comeback
given the pace and you know the way that
the game's been playing so far
yeah it's absolutely possible for fox to
just you know
find an upsmash and tie everything up
but
game 500 bucks winning uh with i gotta
say
you know it's feeling leffen's off the
stage hungrybox it's a mad dog
wow command dog wow oh
some flexing and while both players were
considered two of the best in the world
hungrybox was just a little bit ahead of
leffen he had both the head-to-head
record
and he was the guy winning all the big
tournaments and 2018
four years after their rivalry began was
looking like more of the same
hungrybox was destroying competitive
melee that year winning almost every
major tournament he attended
and leffen whoa starting adams
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
going into evo the biggest smash
tournament of the year
leffen was absolutely winless against
hungrybox bad
to the 3-0 the only game that leffen won
was versus the nest right
yeah but weapon wanted that win he
wanted to take
hungrybox down 66
levin with three stops stalling
that's a little bit of a mistake from
levitt probably you know it could come
back to bite him but
the way this is going it might just not
matter there it is wow
wow after a like losing three socks and
probably the first
minute of the set that was leffen
collects himself uh wins a tight game
too
in a scrap situation and then game three
blows him out of the water what was that
after beating h bonks
leffen continued his momentum eventually
winning his first ever evo title and
carving his name
into melee's history books
armada has no shield armada
absolutely tearing through everyone
today tope
levin is our evo 2018
super smash brothers melee champion
hello ben
i wish somehow i convey the fact that we
both take
competing so seriously we both put
everything we have into it that's why
this game is so draining for us
he's one of the most talented players in
the world one of the highest skill peaks
in the world
and the fact that he was basically able
to almost 3-0 everyone today
on a good day given the pressure given
the circumstance
is a mark of his greatness after leffen
finally overcame his demon and won the
biggest tournament of the year
seemed like the rivalry could finally
come to an end
yeah that didn't happen i have been
pretty upfront about the fact
that i hate him as a person i actually
don't mind him as a competitor really
except for the fact that he cheated at
evo and didn't apologize for it
these days it's harder and harder to
tell if hbox and elephant have buried
the hatchet
but their feud will keep going as long
as they can both wield a controller
because regardless of head-to-head
records community titles or rankings
as long as competitive melee exists
their battle to be number one
will never end
[Music]
yes it's okay
i have no idea i have no idea if this
can even be picked up it's just like
squeaking and squealing of the doors and
[ __ ]
who knows there's also a weird like
buzzing noise
coming from somewhere over that way that
i can't see and it's kind of making me
uncomfortable
no fire alarms though